[Música]
protestas en perú una multitud de
personas pertenecientes a comunidades
campesinas recorrió las calles de lima
exigiendo al gobierno leyes que protejan
a quienes trabajan la tierra en
coincidencia con el primer año del
mandato de pedro castillo las
manifestaciones derivaron en
enfrentamientos con uniformados tenemos
detalles desde el 1
la reserva federal de eeuu anunció una
nueva subida en las tasas de interés un
0.75 por ciento la medida hace parte de
su intento por aliviar la inflación y
descarta otro aumento para septiembre si
la tendencia de los precios altos se
mantiene tenemos reportes de nueva york
hay avances en los diálogos entre
organizaciones civiles y el gobierno
panameño para poner fin a la huelga que
ya completa más de 20 días sin embargo
el sector empresarial advirtió que no
aceptaría un acuerdo alcanzado en la
mesa de conversaciones en la que no se
les incluyó tenemos informe desde ciudad
de panamá
hola y bienvenidos a las noticias de
américa en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz
empezamos en perú campesinos de diversas
regiones del país realizaron una marcha
en lima exigiendo al gobierno de pedro
castillo que este 28 de julio cumple un
año en el cargo en medio de una compleja
crisis política aprobar la denominada
segunda reforma agraria y leyes que
protejan a las mujeres y los hombres que
trabajan la tierra nuestro corresponsal
en lima francisco zacarías estuvo en
esta jornada
solo campesinos de diferentes regiones
de perú quienes cumplen una jornada de
lucha en lima exigiendo el presidente
pedro castillo y el congreso la
reactivación del agro el 5 por ciento
del presupuesto estatal solucionar la
escasez de fertilizantes e impulsar
proyectos de riego y asesoría técnica
pedimos de que dentro de su propuesta de
la economía
y tiene que ir a los pobres a los
campesinos indígenas que garantizamos la
soberanía alimentaria a nuestro país no
estamos pidiendo dádivas estamos
pidiendo el derecho como ser humano y
ciudadano qué hacemos los campesinos
rechazan al parlamento por convocar un
pleno agrarios y tomarlos en cuenta
exige una reforma agraria que permita
combatir la seguridad alimentaria y
promueva la protección de las mujeres y
hombres que cultivan la tierra para
decirle a nuestro presidente de la
república que de una vez por todas pida
cuestión de confianza y disuelve el
congreso y de inmediato también cumpla
con los compromisos asumidos y los
compromisos está la segunda reforma
agraria al igual que diferentes sectores
del perú los campesinos esperan ver
atendidas sus demandas en el mensaje que
el presidente pedro castillo dentro de
pocas horas hará en el congreso en medio
de protestas sociales y con un 74% de
esa población según últimas encuestas
pedro casi de este 28 de julio cumple un
año como presidente de los peruano
pasamos a eeuu la reserva federal volvió
a aumentar las tasas de interés 75
puntos básicos al igual que lo hizo el
mes pasado la medida se dio en medio de
su intento por combatir la inflación el
presidente del banco central
estadounidense no descartó que haya un
nuevo aumento para el mes de septiembre
si la tendencia de los precios altos se
mantiene desde nueva york corazón
económico y financiero de eeuu nuestra
corresponsal mamen sala nos reportaban
previamente los detalles
si la reserva federal se mantiene fiel
en su estrategia de endurecer las
condiciones monetarias en este país y
frenar la inflación de ahí esa subida de
los tipos de interés de 0 75 puntos una
subida agresiva que nunca sea para nada
con la política que hemos visto de la
fed en los tres últimas décadas en las
que esos aumentos o subidas eran tan
sólo de un 0.25 por ciento conduciendo
la economía a un ritmo mucho más lento
es la cuarta subida en lo que va de año
la segunda consecutiva algo histórico lo
que hace dar una idea lo que da una idea
de lo decididos que están a frenar esta
inflación esto qué significa significa
que los préstamos para coches para
vivienda para tarjetas de crédito van a
ser mucho más caros esto hará que los
consumidores pues gasten menos y esto se
espera que frene la inflación justo
después de la reunión ante el comité de
la reserva federal en un comunicado han
anunciado que están dispuestos que el
objetivo es que esa inflación se reduzca
hasta un 2% están dispuestos a seguir
subiendo los tipos de interés recordemos
que ahora mismo la inflación aquí en
eeuu está en un 86 por ciento y en
panamá continúa el diálogo entre
representantes del gobierno y
organizaciones sociales destinados a
poner fin a las protestas que ya se han
extendido durante más de 20 días hasta
ahora se han logrado avances en las
conversaciones y los bloqueos se han
reducido en gran medida para ampliar esa
noticia vamos a esta ciudad de panamá
con nuestro corresponsal oscar sulbarán
oscar cuéntenos cuáles son los nuevos
acuerdos
la mesa de diálogo comenzó el pasado
jueves ya se ha avanzado en temas como
el precio de los alimentos se ha
reducido un 30% la canasta alimentaria
también se ha tratado el tema del
combustible la gasolina ha quedado
fijada en tres puntos 25 dólares por
galón y el tema de los medicamentos es
algo que está en discusión en total son
8 puntos que se van a tratar en esta
mesa de diálogo por cierto el presidente
de la republica a laurentino cortizo se
reunió con representantes de la iglesia
católica quienes son los mediadores en
estos encuentros se ha solicitado la
participación del sector privado en
estas reuniones por otro lado en el país
ya se han levantado los bloqueos que
permanecían en la principal ruta que
conecta
a prácticamente todo el país y también
al país con el resto de centroamérica
sin embargo el gremio docente
se ha mantenido con marchas en varias
ciudades del país
marchas que se realizaron este miércoles
y que están prevista que continúen el
resto de la semana oscar sulbarán
nuestro corresponsal de panamá gracias
por este reporte cambiamos de tema sigue
la visita del papa- francisco en canadá
el pontífice católico llegó a quebec
para reunirse con líderes políticos
entre ellos el primer ministro jostin
trudeau durante su discurso allí no se
desvió del objetivo principal de su
viaje que es pedir perdón a las
comunidades nativas por los abusos a las
que fueron sometidas por parte de la
iglesia católica entre los siglos 18 y
pienso especialmente en las políticas de
asimilación y desvinculación que
incluyen el sistema de escuelas
residenciales y que dañaron
a muchas familias indígenas
- valorando su lengua su cultura
su visión del mundo por lo que expresó
vergüenza
y dolor
y junto con los obispos de este país
renuevo mi petición de perdón por el mal
cometido que tantos cristianos
cometieron contra los pueblos indígenas
y en colombia se han incrementado
dramáticamente las cifras de violencia
en los primeros seis meses del año en
curso así lo evidencia el informe
presentado en bogotá por el comité
internacional de la cruz roja el
documento indicó que el incremento se
evidencia con los recientes ataques del
grupo criminal clan del golfo que está
llevando a cabo un plan para asesinar
policías más de 30 uniformados han
perdido la vida como parte de la
violencia esto tiene lugar a sólo días
de la toma de posesión de gustavo petro
como nuevo presidente de colombia
informe de luís muñoz
las consecuencias humanitarias y la
violencia se intensifican de manera
preocupante en colombia' es la última
alerta del comité internacional de la
cruz roja tras un balance de los
primeros seis meses de 2022
destaca el aumento de un 43% de las
víctimas de artefactos explosivos el
desplazamiento de 70.000 personas y el
confinamiento de otras 19 mil esos
indicadores de consecuencias
humanitarias muestran la difícil
realidad que enfrentan muchas
comunidades en diversos territorios del
país aún así no logran reflejar de
manera completa el temor la zozobra de
desesperanza que producen los conflictos
armados y la violencia en colombia
en la mira de la actualidad el plan
pistola del clan del golfo también auto
denominadas autodefensas gaitanistas de
colombia este grupo armado ilegal habría
matado a más de 30 policías en 2022 la
última ha sido la semana más violenta
para los uniformados en 5 años el
director de la policía nacional el
general jorge luís vargas envió un
mensaje a los colombianos le pido a
todos mis compatriotas
como policía que robe a su policía
nacional
se movilicen en las redes sociales en
las calles apoyando a los policías de
colombia el clan del golfo busca
mostrarse fuerte tras la extradición
este año de su líder alias otoniel y
también igual que otros grupos se erigen
como una estructura unificada de cada
una negociación con el nuevo gobierno de
gustavo petro que ha prometido la
búsqueda de la paz total
puesto
hasta aquí es informativo gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]